[Music]
when I talked to Sean the story he
wanted to tell was really a dynamic true
story about these brothers that was full
of love and compassion and the Nuance of
the relationship there were these kind
of like country boys and they had this
father figure really rode them and drove
them to super stardom now we all know
Carrie's my favorite then Kev then David
then Mike but the rankings can always
change his dad is using his sons to make
his dream when he was younger reality
and teaching them the only way it he
knows how which is to be the biggest the
best the strongest it's hard it drives
all the brothers to various
extremes the von Eric brothers who were
the biggest rock stars in wrestling to
ever come out of
Texas Devon Erics revolutionized the
sport in the
1980s they were Godlike they were like
Comic Book Heroes we knew when we kicked
that door open it was going to blow open
and the people would
freak walking into the ring and being in
the ring together the three brothers
that was a big moment in wrestling where
it was like real rock and roll fandom
that energy was something that we held
as like okay if we can get that right
and I remember the day we shot that we
didn't think of it as a wrestling scene
we thought of it as a scene and what is
the best way to tell a story and the
emotion to connect to whether it's being
close and handheld or being farther away
and zooming in or zooming out we just
approached it like any other scene we
would and made decisions based on that
it was fun it was like a long
choreographed shot as well right was
that the single sort of take deal or DP
Matias he wanted to be in one shot
matius and I would step in and talk
about how we'd shoot it but we
approached it like any scene there was
this kind of really cool rig setup to
pull the camera along and I'll say this
I think we' probably rehearsed it
successfully all the way through with
being on time like maybe once or twice
like where we all hit the moves at the
same time but as soon as we did I think
it was like the First
[Applause]
Take
somehow we came out in full wardrobe
with the full audience and emerged from
backstage walked down and the ri the
match started and we just did it the
first day and we had to like slide under
at the same time to like hit the ring at
the exact same time I think we had ever
done that like no we had we hadn't done
it like real time never it the whole
movie was shot on film and I do feel
like when you shoot on film there is
like a little extra like pressure and
like something kind of magic can happen
really fast
preparing to play Kevin was one of the
most challenging things I've ever done
physically I started the most rigorous
training and diet programs that I've
ever been on in my entire life it was
very tough went sh what me it went so
much deeper than I thought he knew
everything about
me it was a really big insight for me
into who Kevin was it's crazy what
happened to him but you can see the
dedication that he was willing to put
into his physicality and into wrestling
I've been so impressed by Zach his
physical transformation is out of this
world he's super sweet and generous we
just got lucky in the sense that like
Zach his like work ethic and preparation
was so extreme and impressive and then
Harris and I were getting competitive
with our training like a healthy
competition all the wrestling you see in
this movie is done by are actors they
all brought it every single day they
wanted to learn I didn't have to push
them or get them fired
up it was
tough kind of have to do it yourself in
this case you really need to learn the
basics I mean I feel like in the
beginning it was just falling kind of
over and over and over again it was
demanding I mean those those first
couple weeks were they were taxing were
rough we we definitely had some like
bruises and soreness I had to get them
feeling very very comfortable doing that
and it hurts of course I always have
them practice on me so if they're going
to mess up they're messing up on my
face I didn't hit either of you guys I
know I hit Chavo like clean hard in the
jaw one time um but no I definitely hit
Chavo yeah thanks Chavo
sorry 1 2 3
in the scene with Zach and Chavo Kevin
signature move was a flying cross body
off the top rope and I'm going to go
straight up top so don't leave me there
too long okay cross body Chavo played
the Chic and we were walking to the ring
so we could set up and the crowd got on
their feet and started booing and it was
incredible for Zach in particular the
high flying stuff was the focus how he'd
be comfortable flying off the top rope
doing the cross body when we're in the
ring for these highflying
moves it's you just got to go for it you
can't be afraid when you jump 15 ft in
the air you have to jump 15 ft in the
air there's no wires we use no wires
Kevin getting up to the top broke Zack
Efron was coming off the top 15 ft in
the ring not to a crash pad he was to
the map Chava had Zach climb up to the
top rope focusing on this highflying
stuff which is scary and that's a big
fault
really painful it sucks falling on the
mat after you hit your head on it a few
times it's not soft you had some height
yeah you were getting air on those yeah
I remember just being so high over the
ring and Chavo was Tiny and I'm looking
at him like this is going to suck yeah
and I like froze in midair I hit Chavo
super hard and I look up kind of in a
days and I see this guy who is an extra
he stands up and goes W now you're
flying
[Applause]
boy
there you go thanks yeah have a good
one
so what do you want in life Kevin B
Eric more
ribs in the scene with Pam with the
diner Kevin can talk can express himself
she can sort of penetrate the person
she's speaking to and forces them to be
quite vulnerable which really works with
Kevin because he's a really sort of
emotionally repressed person he doesn't
know how to express his feelings I want
to be World Heavyweight Champion
but is that all you
want no of course
not I want to be with my family for me
one of the biggest things about the film
is Kevin not only surviving tragedy but
also shaking the family curse which of
course is not the actual curse but it is
the constructs of masculinity Pam helps
him break this cycle having to be the
best or perfect she kind of represents
unconditional love I don't believe
believe in curses and I don't believe in
luck I think we make our own
[Music]
luck life is hard and you play the cards
are dealt so I just got off my butt and
started Living
again Pam loved it she cried I've say I
cried too you know a couple of times and
I'm not like that they were really each
other's rocks it's a beautiful love
story within such a lot of pain and
sadness and grief he's such an amazing
guy he's like lost so much and then
built everything back up again with his
own family ultimately it's the story of
a guy who
successfully breaks a vicious cycle in
his family and is able to rise
[Music]
above